this morning we continue our special
series kindness 101 with Steve Hartman
sharing stories that are built around
themes of kindness and character and the
people who have mastered those qualities
today's lesson is perseverance Steve and
his kids introduce us to three
persevering students who show us the
power of sticking it out even against
boulder-sized obstacles
good morning this is my daughter Meryl
and we're here to persevere that's right
because we have perseverance for
definition let's go over to my brother
Emma at the dictionary desk on it so I
think that perseverance is like to keep
trying even when there's repeated
obstacles or failures good so we all
know the tortoise beat the hair right
but do you know why was he more talented
no no did he cheat no so how did he do
it the tortoise Despite All Odds even
though he was pretty convinced that he
was going to lose he still tried that's
the point he still tried
perseverance allows you to win in life
even if you're not the fastest smartest
or most talented person in the race all
you've got to do is learn to love a
challenge and never give up no matter
how many setbacks you encounter and of
course I have a story to illustrate a
story pulled from our Archive of amazing
Americans about the power of
perseverance
[Music]
Elementary in North Andover
Massachusetts was honoring three former
students
Alex gamble Kira Brown and Celia desalvo
had just graduated from high school but
the present they left behind when they
were here is still all anyone can talk
about
the kids started working on this gift
unwittingly it was 10 years ago they
were in second grade and out here on the
playground during recess when one of
them saw this little rock or what looked
like a Little Rock sticking up out of
the ground so we kind of thought we were
like oh we should just like we found
some sticks we're like oh let's just dig
this out of the ground they were out
there every recess Richard Cushing was
principal during much of the excavation
and I have to tell you their hats were
broken when when the first Frost
appeared you know because they had to
stop
but year after year they returned to the
project digging mostly with sticks and
plastic spoons they got from the
cafeteria the kids dug down through
second grade third grade fourth and
fifth until finally just before moving
on to middle school they finished the
principal brought in heavy equipment to
lift it out of the hole for them that
was 2008 and now these three are like
rock stars around here it was just in
the ground sticking out a little bit
partly because of the accomplishment
itself try digging out something like
that with just a plastic spoon but
mostly for what The Rock has become it's
evolved into something that we never
could have imagined today some kids say
this rock has the magical power of
making friends
it's a beacon to some of the students
out there who get picked on and they
like go and sit on the Rock and like by
the end of recess someone will go sit
with them I waited there and then
eventually some kids came and that
changed my life forever Walter one
Eureka is a firm believer in the power
of The Rock when I made those friends it
felt magical I thought I would just sit
there alone on recess then friends came
by this is an amazing rock it is you'll
never forget that rock no
not as long as I live
when those three started taking they say
they used to wonder if one day they
would uncover a buried treasure
and now we know
they did
and of course none of that magic would
have happened if those three hadn't
persevered
joining us now Alex Kira and Celia hello
hi hey guys hello I think a lot of kids
would have given up when they started to
see how big that rock was what kept you
going you know we weren't really
thinking about the big picture at the
time we're just taking it one step at a
time and we had to see it through
because we're just those types of people
what were the obstacles that you faced
and like what tried to stop you
so many of the people at school kept
telling us we couldn't do it so that
gave us a motivation to prove to them
that
we believe in ourselves even if you
don't and we're gonna get this done
what's the difference between
perseverance and Obsession because it
seems like you guys were kind of walking
a fine line here
I think it is the fine line that you
need it's like if it's a creative dream
you really have to be obsessed in order
to have the level of like perseverance
to get through and like make it out on
top if I'm ever locked up in Alcatraz I
know who I want myself with me
this up anytime Steve we're here for you
thank you for joining us I really
appreciate it it was great to meet you
guys
you know perseverance can give you the
power to dig a boulder out of the ground
with a plastic spoon you can probably do
anything that's right good luck on
earthing your next treasure and don't
forget to stay kind
and a friend will come to you how about
that I love that they said walk in a
fine line between Obsession and
perseverance yeah you have to be
obsessed with certain things you're
passionate about yeah in order to get to
the end goal I've never found
perseverance to be a bad word right
never I never have I love everything
about Maryland Emmett together it's
always nice